I can see in my country for many people
say they even don't understand what mean
right as a weapon of war they even don't
understand how it can destroy not only
the victim but how rape is destroying
the family the community and all the
country and I think that to really put
attention on this question for me is
very important women are really fighting
a lot to break silence when this
question starts in this region it was
very difficult even you have all
evidence that the women was raped and
she had she was wounded in a very bad
way on the janitor most of the time
women will come with other reasons
because it was a shameful to talk about
what happened but today I can see that
women are more strong to denote to come
directly to the hospital or to police
and say see what happened to me and I
know who is responsible for what I think
that to talk about it his way to just
tell to the perpetrators that if you
make this against me everyone will know
and the shame is not new but the shell
will be to you and I think that we have
to work a lot to transfer that the shell
we shift from victim to perpetrators